لقد تم تهجير جميع سكان غزة تقريبًا،
ومع تقدم الجيش الإسرائيلي الآن
على رافا، يبدو أنه
لم يعد هناك مكان للهرب. ولم تعد باشيا من سي إن إن لديها
المزيد ولكن أولاً تحذير، تقريرها
يحتوي على صور بيانية ومزعجة
محاطة بالفوضى والذعر، والجرحى يرقدون في
صمت.  ألم هذه الفتاة الصغيرة المقنع بالصدمة
إنه أمر مبالغ فيه هذه الأم
تحمي عيني طفلها من الرعب
وتقول له لا
تنظر في الجحيم في مستشفى المعروف أيضًا باسم مارتي،
جثث أولئك الذين لم
ينجوا ملقاة على الأرض  يقول
طبيب ما زال ملطخًا بالدماء هنا إن 14 شخصًا على الأقل
قتلوا نتيجة لسلسلة من
الغارات الجوية التي شنها الجيش الإسرائيلي على
هذا المسجد في المنطقة الوسطى من ديباه،
لكن الجيش الإسرائيلي لم يستجب
لطلب CNN للتعليق على هذا المسجد.  لقد
ترك السكان المحليون هنا للتدقيق في
الأنقاض وانتشال شظايا
جثث القتلى الذين قيل إنهم كانوا
يغادرون المسجد بعد صلاة الفجر،
ولكن كما لم يكن هناك مفر
من الضربات الجوية، يبدو
أيضًا أنه لا يوجد مفر من
الحزن لعائلات غزة  آخر
الضحايا، كبارًا وصغارًا، غادروا للمشاركة في
حدادهم الذي لا ينتهي في
مكان آخر في هذا المستشفى
بوسط غزة، وقد وصل ما لا يقل عن 20 امرأة وطفل
بحثًا عن الأمان
وأجبروا على الفرار مرة أخرى بعد أن
أمرهم الجيش الإسرائيلي بإخلاء
مأواهم في مدينة غزة
[  ضحك]
[موسيقى]
روايات مثيرة للقلق مثل هذه التي شاركتها مع
CNN العديد من النساء اللاتي أُجبرن على الفرار من
وسط غزة، على الرغم من أن CNN لم تتلق أي
تعليق من
الجيش الإسرائيلي. ما هو التالي لهذه
العائلات ولجميع سكان غزة غير واضح،
ولكن لم يتبق سوى أمل ضئيل
في  رفح الآن موطن لأكثر من
مليون فلسطيني، ومدن خيام
للنازحين مستمرة في النمو في هذه المنطقة التي
قيل ذات يوم إنها منطقة آمنة تواجه الآن
غارات جوية لا هوادة فيها.
وحذر وزير الدفاع الإسرائيلي من أن القوات
ستدخل قريبا المدينة الجنوبية التي يقولون إنها
تستهدف
البنية التحتية الإرهابية، ولكن  هناك
مخاوف متزايدة بشأن احتمال حدوث
كارثة إنسانية والتهديد الذي يلوح في الأفق بإراقة
دماء لا توصف في
جنوب شرق شرق البلاد. بشير سي إن إن في لندن